hundreds of unemployment claimants are
fairly worried about not getting paid
this week
they say they're missing a payment
notification on the portal
joe mohler is live at maryland parkway
in sahara with what we know so far about
that joe
yeah well when claimants go to file
their weekly claims what happens is it
posts up on their portal online they're
able to see that well a lot of people
did not
end up getting that last night so of
course they were worried many were
wondering if there was an issue with the
bank that
unemployment uses here bank of america
but dieter just a short time ago did
reach out to us telling us they do know
about this issue
and they are working to repair it it has
to do with an update that they recently
did
be concerned about not getting paid this
week and see it may be like having some
more issues
down the line enrico centaurelli is one
of many missing an online notification
for this week's payment
the thing gets posted after midnight on
monday
so now we are way into tuesday and
nobody has seen any money yet popular
online facebook assistance pages show
there are a number of people in the same
boat
it seems to be like an overwhelming
response of people who didn't get paid
some thought the problem may have come
from bank of america the bank that is
used for benefits
but a representative says they don't
have any signs of an issue
we have seen happen not so much on the
ui side
i think it's kind of like 50 50 at this
point
majorly on the side was that payments
didn't post
amber hansen runs a popular facebook
group where many go to for answers
she says many are trying to get
information from dieter
but she believes it may have something
to do with the bank or the software
used called geographic solutions i just
spoke to one of the administrators of
the
arizona facebook group who also used gsl
as a vendor
and their payments were also delayed
they normally get paid mondays they
didn't get paid until today
okay now back out here live dieter did
you send us an update stating that this
has to do with the update that they're
working on when it comes to the latest
uh coven
relief bill so they are working on that
and they say that
everything should be fixed and repaired
and back up on the portals
later on today so of course we'll keep
an eye on this so the best
idea for you the best thing for you to
do at home is to just keep checking your
portal throughout the night
reporting live here at saharan market
maryland parkway joe moore 8 news now